-Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you, Seth.
-Very happy to have you here.
Obviously this is a book
about endangered species,
and you've been doing
a lot of traveling,
going to different zoos,
and I want to show you a photo.
You met a -- what kind of --
the hellbender.
-A hellbender, we did.
-What is a hellbender?
-A very large salamander.
And I will say, hellbender,
not an attractive animal, but --
-Cute in its own way.
-I will say, you're giving
best effort there.
[ Laughter ]
-It actually was --
Okay, it was a little slimy,
but it also was quite soft.
-Yes, and then who is this,
your friend that touched it?
Who is this that
I'm about to show you?
Do you know?
Because she is not --
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
-She does not seem as happy.
-That's Joy.
-That's Joy?
-Oh, my gosh. I'm so sorry, Joy.
I didn't know this was gonna
happen tonight.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like you're someone
who's just been in politics
a lot longer than Joy.
You're like, no matter
whose hand you're shaking,
you've got to look like
you're engaged.
-Well, and look at Mark,
the keeper,
who has, like, really taken on
trying to save the hellbenders.
They've released 6,000
into the wild.
They're a huge part of what
the St. Louis Zoo is doing.
So, like, look at Mark.
-And Joy just sells him out.
[ Laughter ]
-Joy just, I guess, wasn't up
for it. Oh, my God.
-You know, I think it's very --
-May I take that?
-Yeah, you can have that.
Of course, there you go.
-Thank you.
-I think there are just
a litany of things
that are getting
lost in the shuffle
as far as what's going on with
the current administration.
Conservation is obviously
a huge -- one of those.
Are you -- Obviously,
you're doing your best.
But do you feel like this is
an issue that not only do people
not realize how serious it is,
but also based on the noise,
is impossible to focus on?
-Yeah, I think that a lot of
people don't know how much
the Trump administration has
done to roll back protections
for endangered species.
So, they weakened
the Endangered Species Act.
It's now legal to bring elephant
and lion carcasses and trophies
into the country.
They're planning on opening the
Arctic wildlife natural refuge
to oil drilling.
That would be devastating
for polar bears.
They tried to re-legalize
grizzly bear hunting
in Yellowstone National Park,
something that hadn't been done
in more than 40 years.
So they're really, you know,
pushing back
on endangered species
wherever they can.
-And how do you even
try to explain to people
how serious this is when it
strikes me that, you know --
You've lived in the White House.
This one seems pretty chaotic.
-Yeah, you think?
-Yeah.
-I mean, I would imagine
because of your experience,
you would say to certain people
who have an expectation of what
happens during a presidency,
like, "Trust me, it's a lot
harder than you think it is.
There's a lot more going on."
Are you constantly
taken aback, however,
by exactly how chaotic
this one seems?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-And by the new levels of
cruelty that this administration
seems to find, whether
it's with the children
being separated from
their families at the border
or it's with
the Endangered Species Act,
which had never really been
controversial before.
-Yeah.
-I mean, passed, like,
pretty unanimously,
signed by President
Richard Nixon, of all people.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep. Yeah.
-And yet Trump has made
this controversial, too.
-Right. He believes
that if you're endangered,
you did something wrong.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, and his sons
like to hunt.
-Yeah, they are hunters.
-So I think, kind of, that's
the beginning and the end.
-I would've hoped that if his
sons did it, he would hate it,
and this would be one that would
work in our favor,
but it turns out they're on
the same page on this one.
-Unfortunately.
-I also want to ask -- it must
be very strange that Fox News --
I don't know if you know,
it's a channel --
[ Laughter ]
-I don't watch it.
I am aware of it.
-Yes, you're aware of it,
but you probably are also aware
that your family is still a
topic of obsession for Fox News.
Are you surprised?
Is your mother aware that you
guys are still, sort of --
-Living rent free
in their heads.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
You know,
I do find it bewildering.
I will say if it consumes
time and oxygen to allow
the Democrats in the House
and the Senate,
and in the state houses
and legislatures
to actually get real work done,
I guess I could be
okay with that.
Like, if they're
still obsessing about
my mother's walking
in the woods...
[ Laughter ]
...and it allows Democrats
to actually try to stop
bad things from happening,
and make progress elsewhere,
like, I can live with that.
But I do sometimes wonder, like,
if my mother weren't here --
and I hope she's here for many,
many, many decades to come,
like, what would they
talk about?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It'd be very strange.
-Yes.
-It would just -- like,
"We're back from commercial,
and we're gonna have another one
in five minutes,
and just go about your business,
and we'll go about ours."
[ Laughter ]
I want to ask you, as well.
You have another one on the way.
How are the --
-Yes.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you very much. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-2 and 4 now?
-2 and 4.
-How are 2- and 4-year-olds
reacting to the news?
Are they excited?
-So, our daughter Charlotte
is really excited.
-Uh-huh.
-She loves being a big sister.
I think admittedly she partly
loves being a big sister
'cause her little brother
adores her.
-Oh, there you go. Right.
Build her fan base.
-Yeah, exactly.
I think she sees this as, like,
someone else to adore her.
But she is a really good,
generous-hearted big sister.
I think, though, Aidan is
mainly excited, again --
like, see previous comment about
his adoration of his big sister,
because his big sister
is excited.
So every day Charlotte wants to,
like, touch my belly,
see if she can feel the baby,
talk about the baby,
and then Aidan
will sort of clue in
and be like, "Baby! Yes!"
-And how are your parents
as grandparents?
I mean, I know you're obviously,
you know,
you're gonna grade them well,
but do you feel like
they're doing a good job?
-I think they're doing
a really good job.
They're really involved,
which I love.
And I love watching them read
and sing and play with our kids.
I definitely have, like,
really dropped on
the ladder of importance.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Like, whole conversations now
happen while I will have
hung up the phone or gotten off
Facetime, and I'm like,
"They never asked how I was."
[ Laughter ]
And that's okay.
-I think that happens.
I think that happens everywhere.
-Natural order. Yeah.
-Thank you, as always,
for being here.
Thanks for writing the book.
-Thank you, Seth.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
-That's Chelsea Clinton,
everybody.